Họng hôm sống thuần bày tác, lượng viện của họ Mỹ đã thông qua sự lợt mở lại chính phủ,
chăm rất đỏng cửa dài nhất trong lịch sử.
Tuy nhiên, thật tòa này không mang lại chính tháng sống sàng cho bất kỷ phê nào,
khi những mất đồng về chính xác chi tiêu và bảo hiểm ý tế vẫn chưa được xa quyết.
Các chứ dành định, của hùng ál vừa qua đã cây tổn thân nghiêm trọng cho cảnh điểm tinh tế,
và quý tính chính trị của 2 đảng lớn.
Theo phản phẩm ngươi sức của hội, thì thải tinh tế hước tình lên tưởng người bỗn tỷ đồ là Mỹ,
hôm vụ đã khó phục hạt động, phát nhà phân tích cảnh báo, tình trạng đối đồng giữa 2 đảng.
Khó tế tại phá bởi đầu năm nay nguyên không tra mi sấu khi ngần xác mới được chính lên.
Vô qua xác cho sang vì đặt lưỡi chính trị lên trên lưỡi khu sa đang làm suy yếu nghiêm tên của cửa chi vau khả nâng điệu 2 ngua khách tình.